[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour faire le tour de l'actualité
locale bienvenue dans cette édition
voici les titres de ce mercredi 27
janvier le texte est en débat depuis
hier soir à l'assemblée nationale les
députés planchent sur le projet de loi
sur la maltraitance animale un sujet
porté notamment par la parlementaire
yvelinoise aurore bergé responsable du
texte pour la majorité
elle était récemment à bazoches sur
guyonne pour le présenter le colis de 19
a aussi des conséquences sur la justice
dans les yvelines par exemple plus de
2200 dossiers sont en attente au
tribunal de versailles est dix fois plus
qu'en janvier à 2020 explications à
suivre et invités maryvonne caillibotte
procureur de la république de versailles
enfin plus que quelques heures avant
l'arrivée de louis burton aux sables
d'olonne skipper de rambouillet devrait
boucler le vendée globe cette nuit après
81 jours en mer nous serons de nouveau
sur place à la fin de ce long
[Musique]
depuis hier les députés examinent le
projet de loi contre la maltraitance
animale une loi portée notamment par
aurore bergé et députée de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines et des
sanctions plus sévères des interdictions
de vente ou encore des certificats de
connaissances sont au coeur de cette
nouvelle législation dont les grandes
lignes ont été présentées en fin de
semaine dernière c'était à la fondation
brigitte bardot à bazoches sur guyonne
les précisions de mélanie poké il faudra
bientôt montrer patte blanche pour
adopter détenir un animal les futurs
adoptants pourrait ne plus trouver leur
chien ou leur chat dans des animaleries
avec la loi sur la maltraitance animale
les amoureux des bêtes devront notamment
obtenir un certificat de connaissances
celui qui devient propriétaire saura à
quoi il s'engage sera ce qu'on attend de
lui et ça lui permettra d'être mieux
éclairer sur son choix parce qu'on peut
avoir envie d'un chien mais peut-être
que c'est pas la bonne catégorie 2
chiens la bonne taille parce que telle
ou telle espèce requiert plus
d'attention et peut être aussi plus de
soins vétérinaires à terme des sanctions
plus lourdes en cas de maltraitance
qu'elle soit volontaire ou liées à la
méconnaissance de l'animal
les peines encourues vont de 1 à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement l'amande peut monter
jusqu'à soixante quinze mille euros
parmi les autres articles de la loi
l'interdiction progressive d'animaux
sauvages dans les cirques et l'élevage
de vison pour leur fourrure
ce que je souhaite aujourd'hui ce qui
n'existe pas en france mais je préfère
qu'on pose des garde-fous c'est qu'on
élargisse cette interdiction à
l'ensemble des animaux sauvages de
manière à ce qu'on n'est pas demain
l'idée de quelqu'un d'ouvrir un élevage
de fourrure
renard par exemple un texte attendu par
les associations à bazoches sur guyonne
la fondation brigitte bardot accueille
plusieurs centaines de compagnons à
quatre pattes chats chiens et animaux de
ferme
c'est très important de voir qu'il ya
enfin une réponse politique à la tante
sociétal dont ça fait des décennies
maintenant qu'on travaille avec les
politiques successifs sans obtenir aucun
résultat alors ce cette proposition de
loi
elle ne répond pas à toutes nos attentes
bien évidemment il ya des sujets comme
la chasse l'élevage intensif la corrida
et d'autres qui ne sont pas abordées
mais ça amorce un changement et ça c'est
véritablement nouveau la loi doit être
examiné à l'assemblée nationale jusqu'au
29 janvier
la france compte 63 millions d'animaux
de compagnie sur cette thématique
d'ailleurs la région ile de france a
lancé de son côté son label ville amie
des animaux il pourra être affiché à
l'entrée des communes qui améliorent la
place des animaux sur trois critères le
respect du bien-être animal la
valorisation de la place des animaux de
compagnie et puis le renforcement de
leur place auprès des citoyens
fragilisés quarante quatre villes
franciliennes sont labellisés en
obtenant de une à trois pattes 500 dans
les yvelines
conflans sainte honorine l'aube sienne
et vernouillet avec deux pattes une pâte
pour vélizy villacoublay et mantes la
ville dans l'actualité également la
fermeture de ce lycée à maule son nom le
buat c'est un cas positif aux colis de
19 qui a poussé les autorités à prendre
ses décisions également plusieurs cas
contacts dans le personnel de cet
établissement privé agricole sur les
a380 lycéens et bts 200 sont invités à
rester chez eux pour suivre et les cours
à distance pour une durée d'une semaine
décision notamment pour anticiper le
manque de personnel dont plusieurs
membres ont été placés à l'isolément
les élèves devraient faire leur retour
en classe en présentiel dès le 1er
février
par ailleurs on a appris aujourd'hui que
le variant anglais ducobu 19 représenter
10% des cas positifs en ile-de-france
résultats d'une analyse effectuée entre
le 11 et le 21 janvier dans huit sites
de dépistage francilien d'après
l'assistance publique hôpitaux de paris
cela pourrait augurer une prochaine
hausse très significative du variant
dans les prochaines semaines
conséquence du coc vide 19 notamment du
retard dans les procédures judiciaires
plus de 2200 dossiers sont en attente au
tribunal judiciaire de versailles
à dix fois plus d'affaires reporté par
rapport à la fin d'année 2010 9 pour
parler de ce sujet en visioconférence
maryvonne caillibotte bonsoir bonsoir
procureur de la république de versailles
et également avec mon plateau nicolas
dans driss bonsoir de la rédaction de tv
78 comment peut-on expliquer nicolas ce
retard accumulé et bien grégory je vous
propose de revenir en mai 2020 quelques
semaines après le déconfinement souvenez
vous de ces images du tribunal
judiciaire de versailles organisé pour
accueillir de nouveau des audiences et
du public
une reprise de l'activité après la
fermeture de l'institution pendant le
premier confinement les dossiers se sont
empilées les délais sont rallongés et
comme vous l'avez dit à la fin de
l'année 2020 il ya eu un retard avec
2200 dossiers en attente au tribunal
judiciaire de versailles
avec des conséquences pour les
justiciables à ce propos on écoute
l'avocate
florence mercadet choqué avocate au
barreau de versailles pour les
justiciables c'est quelque chose de
novateur puisque vous commencez à un
procès et vous n'avez une décision d'un
tribunal judiciaire que peut-être un an
et demi ou deux ans après et après vous
devez avoir 6000 ya un appel au moins 18
mois de délai donc on se retrouve avec
des profs et qui peuvent durer jusqu'à
quatre ans avant d'avoir une décision
qui tranche le problème auparavant on
pouvais avoir c'était déjà loin de toute
façon on pouvait avoir une décision d'un
tribunal judiciaire entre 10 et 12 mois
et une décision devant la cour d'appel à
peu près dans les douze mois donc ça
s'est multipliée par 2 des conséquences
pour les justiciables mais aussi des
conséquences dans l'activité des avocats
écouté il faut rouvrir des dossiers
imaginons que le dossier soit totalement
en état ce à dire qu'on n'est plus rien
à à ce communiqué ni comme un élément
procédure aux pièces que l'on communique
entre ce moment là et le moment où on
plaide on peut avoir un homme distant
qui veut dire que déjà éventuellement la
situation de nos clients puissent
changer en cuir et puis aussi il faut
qu'on se remette dans le dossier que
canda plutôt oublié après un non parce
que d'autres dossiers se sont mis par
dessus et donc ça devient très compliqué
en termes de gestion de dossiers
a compris à la crise sanitaire première
cause à laquelle on pense est elle pour
autant la seule responsable nicollin
alors locaux se disent notez bien
évidemment le principal facteur
explicatif de ce retard pris par le
tribunal judiciaire de versailles
mais la grève des avocats des buts 2020
contre la réforme des retraites avait
déjà entraîné des retards dans certaines
procédures
rappelez vous de ces manifestations dans
les rues de paris en février 2020 ou
encore de ce flash mob des avocats du
barreau de versailles devant le château
une question madame le procureur
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète le plus par
rapport à ces retards pris par le
tribunal judiciaire de versailles
mais ce qui soucie le plus les
magistrats en charge d'une juridiction
c'est le retard pris dans le jugement
des dossiers ou dans le traitement des
dossiers parce que en fait derrière un
dossier il ya un justiciable et donc
forcément ce sont des gens qui attendent
que la justice leur soit rendue
donc c'est une véritable obsession de
notes par de rendre cette justice qu'on
attend de nous donc effectivement vous
avez cité parmi les retards que nous
avons accumulée au cours des années 2020
deux raisons qui se sont cumulées la
grève des avocats qui étaient tout à
fait inédite dans son ampleur dans sa
durée dans sa dureté de certaines
manières aussi et puis la crise qu vide
qu'il a nous a confronté à une situation
encore plus inédites et que personne
d'entre nous n'avait jamais connu qui
est une partie de la fermeture du
tribunal
et encore l'activité pénale est celle
qui a le moins souffert parce que à
cette époque-là en 2020 ça paraît déjà
un peu loin c'est la matière pénale ou
en tout cas les magistrats qui tiennent
de la matière pénale qui était
suffisamment doter en matériel
informatique pour pouvoir continuer une
activité
outre la nécessité de garder une
activité pénale d'urgence pour traiter
les infractions qui continuait malgré
tout de se commettre malgré de
confinement alors là vous parlez d'un
matière pénale qu'elles sont du coup
couler les activités les matières qui
ont pris le plus de retard le clairement
les matières qui ont pré la matière qui
a pris le plus de retard c'est la
matière civile donc le tout ce qui est
la matière civile le pur et puis
également tout ce qui est le secteur des
affaires familiales
même si beaucoup d'efforts ont été faits
par les collègues les magistrats le
président du tribunal qui était en
charge du tribunal à l'époque
malgré tout l'activité s'est arrêtée
caillebotte il restait deux cent
soixante treize dossiers en attente
alors même si un an plus tard c'est dix
fois plus est ce que cette situation de
retard avoir du retard dans les dossiers
est fréquente dans le monde de la
justice
vous savez un tribunal c'est une
capacité de jugement qui est lié au
nombre de ses fans tout simplement au
nombre de magistrats de fonctionnaires
et puis aussi aux disponibilités des
justiciables de leurs conseils et tout
ça fait que malgré un audiencement un
peu l'idéal les affaires ne passe pas
forcément ne s'excuse pas forcément un
rythme suffisamment rapide donc en fin
d'année 2010 9 quand on a un petit peu
plus de 200 affaires qui attendent
d'être jugés c'est toujours trop pour
les personnes qui sont derrière
mais c'est un chiffre extrêmement
raisonnable ça jeu il faut l'assumer
quant à la fin de l'année 2020 alors le
chiffre de 2200 est pas tout à fait
l'équivalent en réalité à la fin de
l'année 2020 on à 700 procédure qui
attendent d'être audience et donc vous
voyez la relation est un peu différente
par rapport à 2010 à 2019
néanmoins c'est un saut absolument
énorme donc le chiffre de 2200
correspond aux procédures qui sont
arrivés et qu'ils n'ont pas pu être
enregistrée par ce que les piles se sont
formés et les journées ont des débuts et
des femmes nicolas landré la crise
sanitaire a aussi eu des conséquences
par rapport aux prisons vous avez vu des
consignes de la part du ministère
pendant l'année qu'il fallait peut-être
procéder à des libérations anticipées
quel bilan vous faites de ce dispositif
dans le département alors effectivement
ça a été un gros sujet de travail au
cours de l'année 2020 d'abord parce
qu'effectivement l'idée c'était d'éviter
que les prisons deviennent des clusters
à la fois pour les détenus mais
également pour les personnels compte
tenu des conditions dans lesquelles les
gens soient incarcérés notamment pour ce
qui concerne versailles la maison
d'arrêt de bois d'arcy qui est le plus
gros des établissements et ça se
conjuguer avec la mise en oeuvre aussi
de là
la loi de programmation sur la justice
qui nous entraînait dans une réforme des
peines très importante très essentiel
conduisant à limiter au plus possible et
les peines d'emprisonnement
donc les deux conjugués et les
instructions effectivement assez
formelle de la centrale nous ont
conduits à prendre des décisions très
soigneusement pesé avec des critères
pour parvenir à des libérations plus ou
moins anticipée en fonction des
situations et donc on a obtenu comme ça
effectivement une et on a assaini la
situation de bois d'arcy notamment de
manière extrêmement substantiel qui a
permis d'éviter des contaminations chez
les détenus et de limiter très fortement
les atteintes chez les personnels
pénitentiaires
une émission de deux dernières questions
maryvonne caillibotte pour attraper
justement ce retard il ya la solution de
la dématérialisation des procédures les
audiences à distance qui a été notamment
vous avez eu recours à ses solutions en
2020 est ce que ça a bien fonctionné
est ce que le but c'est de l'amplifier
sûr sur cette année 2021 alors
l'audience à distance ça consiste en
fait à à juger quelqu'un qui n'est pas
physiquement là mais une audience elle
peut toujours contenir un nombre limité
de dossiers
si on juge 10,12 à faire dans une
audience le fait que ce soit en
visioconférence ou en présentiel ne fera
pas une accélération une diminution
voire même d'ailleurs bon donc le
recours à la visio c'est effectivement
quelque chose qui à la fois simplifie et
puis aussi permet de respecter les
gestes barrière évite les extractions
des détentions donc des allées venues
voyez entre eux un tribunal une prison
et ses terres avec des gens qui
s'occupent des transfèrements mais ça a
ses limites
et en plus on recourt à la visio pose
aussi des questions plus idéologique qui
ne tendent pas actuellement et on peut
regarder la dernière décision du conseil
constitutionnel à aller vers un
élargissement n'ont pas forcément
d'amplification en 2021 on espère un
maintien mais
des mythes contenu ça c'est sûr merci
maryvonne caillibotte d'avoir été avec
nous je me sens pris bonsoir je rappelle
que vous êtes le procureur de la
république de versailles merci à nicolas
landry de la rédaction de tv 78 au
chapitre politique une nouvelle
candidate pour la présidence de la
région ile de france il s'agit d'audrey
pulvar qui l'annoncé ce matin dans les
colonnes de nos confrères du parisien
l'ancien journaliste aujourd'hui adjoint
danny anne hidalgo à paris va mener une
liste de gauche ile-de-france en commun
elle sera composée de personnalités
engagées dans la société civile a
indiqué audrey pulvar parmi les mesures
phare qu'elle souhaite défendre la
gratuité des transports en commun pour
tous à partir de 2026 face à la
présidente sortante de la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse qui
conduirait une liste de la droite et du
centre
clémentine autain pour la france
insoumise le rassemblement national
pourrait être représentée par jordan
bardella et jean michel blanquer air
était pressenti lui de son côté pour la
liste la république en marche même s'il
a botté en touche cette semaine le
scrutin aura lieu en juin prochain
les deux collectivités sont réunis au
sein d'un établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines et
hauts-de-seine ont voté leur budget
commun pour 2021 les élus l'ont voté à
l'unanimité ce mardi 26 janvier à la
scène musicale à boulogne billancourt
16,3 millions d'euros est dédié à 3
politique commune l'entretien et
l'exploitation des routes
départementales l'arc et le
l'archéologie préventive et l'adoption
confirmant la continuité des deux
départements dans leur volonté de
collaborer les propos recueillis par
nicolas landry sa jane continuité y'a
papa d'innovation un majeur
l'établissement public
interdépartemental fait ses preuves à la
fois parce qu'il permet des économies
parce qu'ils permettent de financer des
politiques communes donc
bien que la crise d'abord sanitaires
mais bientôt social et économique arrive
nous continuons à avoir un budget
ambitieux ça traduit deux départements
qui avancent tranquillement
même s'ils n'ont toujours pas ces deux
départements obtenu de réponse de l'état
ils avancent dans leur collaboration
parce qu'elle se fait dans l'intérêt de
nos populations
jusqu'au 9 février les votes sont
ouverts pour la fabrique à l'ifa un
concours national de l'entrepreneuriat
social et solidaire parmi les
participants l association ou mensah
effet children basée à saint germain en
laye pris en charge et accueille les
femmes et les enfants victimes ou
témoins de violences remporté le
concours pour l aider à agir partout en
france
interview express
moman cf en fête est née d'un constat
celui de l'universalité des violences
faites aux femmes et aux enfants et en
absence de dinde une réponse adéquate on
a créé en 2014
un lieu qui réunit en a même mieux donc
des juristes des avocats des médecins
donc on réunit en fait la santé et la
justice pour traiter des situations de
violence quelle que soit la forme de
violence des femmes et des enfants
absolument on a cette ambition là elle
ne correspond à une réalité de terrain
c'est en fait répondre beaucoup plus aux
besoins locaux sur le territoire en
dupliquant fait une expertise qui marche
bien aujourd'hui les femmes viennent de
51 départements
je pense qu'il faut maintenant réfléchir
à aller plus vers elle sait aussi nous
permettre de transmettre des savoirs
acquis par notre équipe d'experts etc en
fait modéliser un centre qui prend en
charge dans un même mieux donc les
femmes et les enfants et que dans cette
prise en charge est absolument
indispensable que l'enfant puisse aussi
avoir son espace de parole et donc il a
été créé depuis 2010 est donc qu'il ya
des enfants qui aujourd'hui sont
intégrés dans notre réseau
alors ce concours effectivement il est
porté par la fabrique à visa et ses
partenaires qui propose en fait
d'appuyer des projets avec un impact
social important
l'enjeu est important puisque nous
cherchons des ressources financières
privées au delà des soutiens publics que
nous recevons aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin effectivement de ce type de
soutien
alors là l'enjeu c'est une somme de 60
mille euros qui pourrait effectivement
être est reversé plus cent mille euros
si nous devions être les premiers de ce
va dire de ce panel de porteurs de
projets sociaux le sport à présent comme
milliards direction les sables d'olonne
en vendée bonsoir michael et demi d'euro
bonds sans grégory pour la rédaction de
tv 60,18 vous êtes sur place pour vivre
les dernières heures de ce vendée globe
la course autour du monde à la voile en
solitaire sans escale ni assistance et
parmi les skippers en lice dans le haut
du classement 1 yvelinois louis burton
sur bureau vallée 2 quelles sont les
dernières nouvelles michael est ce qu'il
va arriver prochainement sur place will
burton et et surtout en quelle position
c'est la question que l'on se pose
il y est presque un grégory plus que
quelques heures à attendre il sera sur
la terre ferme ici où je me trouve
il devrait arriver entre 23h et 1h du
matin il devra ensuite répondre aux
questions des 300 journalistes qui sont
sur place et j'espère qu'il répondra à
nos questions en particulier au niveau
du classement les dernières nouvelles
sont assez bonnes l'yvelinois louis
burton avance vite 33 km heure de
moyenne et il pointe actuellement à la
deuxième place du classement à quelques
heures de l'arrivée la dépasser
aujourd'hui l'allemand à boris herrmann
qui ne dépassera pas le premier charlie
dalin qui arrivera un premier aux sables
d'olonne dans une heure environ à tous
les équipages sont en train de se
préparer
derrière moi mais attention à gregorio
louis burton n'est pas sûr de terminer à
sur le podium boris herrmann pourrait
bénéficier de sa bonification de six
heures il pourrait donc chiper cette
deuxième place cette fameuse deuxième
place à louis burton et surtout yannick
bestaven pourrait lui aussi dû passer
devant à sa bonification de 10h15
pour résumer dans cette dernière ligne
droite inédite
louis burton peut terminer entre la
2e et la 5e place ce qui n'est jamais
arrivé dans l'histoire c'est surtout que
tous ces bateaux se retrouvent ensemble
et que les écarts soient aussi a réduit
en tout cas pour le frère de louis
burton nelson louis burton a réalisé un
tour du monde exceptionnelle et il
espère en tout cas que il aura plein de
souvenirs en écoute justement nelson sur
7 sur la performance de libertad c'est
la fin d'une aventure incroyable s'il ya
90 jours on nous avait dit que ça allait
se passer comme ça je pense qu'on aurait
signé tout de suite
d'une part parce que
il va terminer devant d'autre part parce
que a priori l'objectif sportif sera
rempli par rapport à ce qu'ils s'étaient
fixé qui était d'être dans le top 5
et puis surtout parce que ça court ça a
été tellement incroyable et parsemé
d'embûches avec le pit stop à macquarie
avec les ennuis qu'il a eue en dans la
descente de l'atlantique à refaire sa
cloison avec la remontée incroyable qui
fait dans la fin de l'indien dans le
pacifique jusqu'à être premier au
passage de l'équateur et je viens de
l'apprendre l'instant n'arrivera pas
avant 23h30 et on le voit il y a
beaucoup de brume autour de moi vous
voyez juste deux mois si vous voulez
suivre cette fin de course il faudra
donc s'armer de patience et surtout
boire de bonne dose de café
grégory moi je pense que j'en aurai a
bien besoin on va suivre ça avec
attention on reviendra en tout cas
demain sur cette arrivée louis burton et
d'ailleurs je crois à michael que vous
allez monter à bord d'un bateau pour
suivre cette arrivée soyez prudents et
revenez nous entier dans les yvelines
merci d'avoir été décriée en tout cas à
grégory merci d'avoir est avec mickaël
avant de refermer ce journal j'accueille
mélanie poquet autre journaliste de la
rédaction au plateau bon soir vous êtes
la présentatrice haussier de l'émission
7 8 sociétés qui arrive dans un instant
sur tv 78 et ce soir vous nous parler de
la jeunesse en cette période de colis de
19 ans risque en décembre 2020 une
commission denquête de l'assemblée
nationale présenté les résultats de plus
de 80 heures d'audition et je cite des
constats alarmants +2 50% des jeunes
sont inquiets sur leur santé mentale 30%
ont renoncé aux soins faute de moyens et
21 % des 18-25 ans sont au chômage alors
avec mes invités nous ferons un état des
lieux dans la situation dans les
yvelines
trois jeunes partageront leurs
expériences et sandrine busto six
collègues voisins bretons ne nous
apportera elle son éclairage merci
mélanie le 7-8 société c'est dans un
instant sur tv 60,18 voilà c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de votre fidélité
très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]